punching Skyward and on high alert this
Soviet anti-aircraft gun was built in
1982
the man at its controls are members of a
mobile air defense unit trying to
protect the Ukrainian capital and
surrounding area from Russian so-called
Kamikaze drone and missile attacks
some of the ammunition was taken from a
similar Russian weapon captured around
butcher in the early days of the war
other soldiers carry portable
heat-seeking Soviet post-soviet and
Western Stinger missiles
the commander says they are effective up
to a range of six kilometers but often
find it difficult to latch onto the
drones that Russia is using to Target
Ukraine's electricity grid
131 and 136 Kamikaze drones are low
speed visible and loud but they have a
small Heat Signature it can be difficult
to lock onto the Target and the missile
might miss
anti-aircraft guns work most effectively
against the Shaheed but they have a
problem if the Drone flies at night or
in conditions of poor visibility
Russian forces have carried out at least
a thousand drone and cruise missile
attacks targeting energy infrastructure
in the last two and a half months
most like this one are intercepted
but many gets through some millions of
ukrainians are suffering blackouts and
poor Heating in freezing winter
conditions
Ukraine's Western backers have sent air
defense weapons such as this Nissan
system and last week the US announced it
is supplying a patriot missile system
but training how to use it can take
months
and one missile costs up to four million
dollars
the commander of this unit says it will
be used to predict only the most
important potential targets and cannot
be deployed to intercept drones and
cruise missiles
as we were filming this mobile air
defense unit
the sound of a siren can be heard in the
distance and as a result as you can
imagine
these men are now on the move
we were not allowed to follow the
soldiers because at the risk of giving
away their locations but in another
field close to Kiev this mobile air
defense unit practices using a machine
gun with a range of around three
kilometers it can easily take down the
Kamikaze drones that flies around 160
kilometers an hour only to get eyes on
first
drones are less difficult than missiles
but there are observational difficulties
because they can fly over forests that
hide them or over busy roads where their
approach noise is drowned out by traffic
uh-huh despite the challenges they face
there are hundreds of men like these
across the country constantly ready for
a radio alert
focused on the skies
Charles traffic Al Jazeera key of region
Ukraine